the wall street journal when an amateur
challenge is a grand master there
chest um why is it so hard to find there
it is
i found it oh my god it has 8 million
views holy smokes
all right let's watch
can you guys see it even if i full
screen it
and can you can you listen can you hear
it
[Music]
the final challenge is to defeat world
champion magnus carlson
at a game of chess
[Music]
okay i made it much louder
all right so uh who am i i'm max deutsch
i'm 24 years old i live in san francisco
and i would consider myself an extreme
learner extreme learner yes
okay he masters a new skill every month
okay
as humans i think we always want a new
challenge or to feel
personal growth or experience new things
and i think
learning is one of the ways to do that
memorize okay
in many ways learning a new skill the
feeling you get is often akin to
traveling where you're in a new
environment
or you're experiencing your stimulus
anything wrong with that i think
everyone can relate to that feeling of
being in a new place and traveling and
for me and i think for many people
learning something new can also trigger
those same
experiences
the final challenge is to defeat world
champion magazine that's ridiculous
yeah i think the problem is not that he
does a new skill every month he just
thinks that chess is like the next skill
that he can master
like you can't compare that to mastering
a backflip
that's insane and like i like the the
gleeful smile like yes i'm just gonna do
this
[Music]
could i reimagine or create a completely
different way of thinking about chess
where that i could play a competitive
game in only a month's time
[Music]
i am my name is carlson from norway
i am 26 years old and i'm currently
ranked number one
in the world in chess
[Music]
i have agreed this challenge because
i'm genuinely curious to
beat him to what he's able to and i
think he was curious
in a month do you think he'll beat you
um
no but i've been surprised before you
can't hear me
i first sat down to try to figure out
how i could possibly
play a competitive game against magnus
with only a month of training and i very
quickly realized
that i just couldn't climb that chess
skill ladder fast enough in a month and
so really
so if i wasn't going to learn chess like
a human the other option i had was to
learn chess
like a computer the idea is that ah
if only we all knew this secret could i
build an algorithm in my computer that
looks at any given chess position
um and without having to go any further
any deeper could say whether that's a
favorable position or not
not to [ __ ] on my own city this this
person could only live in san francisco
i would ultimately turn my brain into a
very slow
and slightly less sophisticated chess
computer
one thing that i did not anticipate was
how long it would take my computer to
come up with this algorithm and so as
we're speaking right now my computer is
still chugging away
so right now as i'm sitting here i have
nothing memorized
i think the game starts in the next
three hours so
cutting it really close only magnus has
gotten to the level that magnus plays
but most people spend
years of their life getting to a very
high level in this game
really i didn't know that i've seen
magnus play
on the internet but never in person
so i'm excited to experience the first
in-person game
uh from the other side of the board let
me just point out do they not have a
chest clock they have to use a phone
they have to use a smartphone as a chest
clock that already tells you a lot about
this experiment
really unfortunately i ran out of time
the chess algorithm is still
processing coming together and as a
result
i completely abandoned that approach for
today and just played a normal game of
chess
the first five moves
no i mean the first like 10 moves were
very very good
keeping him a little bit nervous for at
least eight moves was a
a minor victory and then after move 12 i
really my pieces were just dancing
around
you were very serious i moved my knight
here and you twitched a little bit like
you
you realized that it was gonna be uh
okay yeah
yeah yeah even though this final
challenge i didn't quite succeed in the
way that i was hoping
uh it was one of the most interesting
experiences of all the 12 challenges so
i'm definitely glad i had it
[Music]
now i'm really curious as to how your
algorithm is going to
work out yeah if it works you up for
another game
yeah sure yes
all right well
that's that that was hilarious um
yeah magnus is being really professional
that was really cringe
that was really cringe escarancho thank
you
okay i think i think in that guy's
defense um
he like fits these like silicon valley
kind of stereotypes and he doesn't try
to
he doesn't exactly try to avoid them and
i'm sure he's
he's smart and he's he's mastered some
skills before but
i mean you can't you just can't approach
something like that with
this much like disrespect i mean i mean
it's just
it's just disrespectful so but it's it's
funny
yeah no i know the smile was the most
annoying part i mean it's funny
but he was a fool in this case
[Music]
you